citizens of the reject Nation we're
gonna watch Brooklyn nine nine four by
Seventeen today it's called copcon
Capcom alrighty guys well you know what
to do please go ahead leave a like
that's gonna be the most appreciated
thing on this planet at this moment and
uh full anthraction watch Longs we
single with your own copy of Brooklyn
Nine-Nine available for our super sexy
rejects we cover several things
exclusively over there with the reaction
highlights and watch alongs included and
yeah let's uh I'll see what's going on
with Brooklyn
yeah
oh it's coca fell asleep in the break
room so I put his hand in a bowl of warm
water come on man that's the stupidest
prank ever uh no it's the smartest
because it involves biology yes it does
you have to clean that up dude he's
drowning
take it back Jake great pranks
cut it right what is
Reddit no let me tell you how to edit
your comedy is everyone packed for the
28th Annual Tri-State police officers
convention yes talk about can't miss
yeah we don't really go for the talks
we're more interested in the
extracurriculars part five of course oh
we are all about free hotel rooms I get
to sleep in a bed by myself no wife no
kids just Terry Star fishing on a cow
king nice the Buffalo PD always throws
an insane party last year Amy got so
drunk she jumped a police horse into the
pool Adrian gave me as an equestrian and
she's real bad at it
believe in yourself sir it's been a hard
year I mean frankly we could all use a
party to blow off some steam first we
were on the night shift and the precinct
almost got shut down I got hit by a bus
oh yeah serial details that's why I'm
running for a seat on the convention's
board of directors if I win it will look
good for the precinct so please don't do
anything to jeopardize that dismissed
okay we're still gonna have a great time
there's one thing I know it's how to
sneak out to a party without your
parents finding out I used to do it all
the time did you now to go to a magic
the Gathering tournament I got stuck in
the window like Winnie the Pooh there
okay now you know everything my mom had
to pull me back in by my ponytail all
right let's party
hey hey what's up BPD AKA Buffalo party
Department
it's coming tonight right obviously it's
the only reason any of us are cops all
right detectives you guys finding a
party no we were just debating our
favorite parts of the conference he
likes his q and A's moderated I like
mine unmoderated why is that
[Music]
oh look this
long-range heartbeat
to tell your human pulse through walls
oh that sounds cool I'm so sorry excuse
me
it's like a she Scully I'm high uh Norm
uh who are you shats
your hands are so clammy I ate a bunch
of clams earlier and they still smell oh
anyway it was so nice to meet you I'll
see you around oh you blew it oh Scully
I was just talking to that amazing woman
and I blacked out did I get her number
no you chunked it of course I did I'm no
Hitchcock when it comes to the lady oh
he's Fearless I once saw a mascot a
breastfeeding mother wow
oh my man here let's wait here a second
see if our future selves show up and
tell us to destroy it nope looks like
we're in the clear it's kind of cute hey
check it out it's called The Wasp oh
Batman and it's a sadly you could only
hear if you're 35 or under
um
definitely here
hold still I'm gonna hide behind you
like your tree on the other side of your
trunk is the worst person I've ever met
Captain Jeffrey Boucher Raymond halt as
I live and breathe my man hey I wanted
to tell you that I am also running for
the board of directors I've been up for
promotions against that man on six
occasions and he's prevailed every
single time isn't it possible he gets
promotions because he's nice and it's
fake it's fake Hulk went to bed early
because his big speech is in the morning
because his breakfast order is hanging
on the doorknob muffin comma English and
that means it's time for us too hard
comma party yeah comma oh they've been
taking bribes no it was because of the
party that's what you should tell
everyone man they've been taking bribe
it's not happening that means we're just
hotel in Rochester
this is a nightmare I learned a bunch of
new dance moves for tonight once where
you move your butt throw the part of
yourselves we're gonna take matters into
our own hands nine nine style that's
right my friends the nine nine is
throwing a bit can I borrow 200 for
alcohol the 99 is throwing a party
talk to some of the vendors at the tech
expo and they agreed to hook us up for
the party check it out disco lights
sound system beer cooler leak-free
insulated body bag our beer is dying to
get inside ah this room is all the way
across the hotel from ours he insisted
so he'd have a view of the Rochester
Skyline uh drink it in Peralta the
mustard city
that's a big old blown up still image I
mean all he's doing is standing guard I
mean I could do that awesome if you do
that then K13 can come to the party I am
programmed to Boogie my butt no I'm
going to the party people for me over a
robot I do Charles it's like a bunny
rake concert in here now remember
what's the taser challenge we tase each
other then drink how do you win what are
you a lawyer
he knows not to oh you're writing that
down this is good stuff what else you
got don't talk about your foot fungus
don't talk about your eye fungus let's
just say fungus is off the table
cordyceps believe in yourself be
confident you're a sweet guy with a big
heart it's the size of a giraffe's
pushes on my other organs okay you got
this don't talk about the draft doing
great buddy
hi Cindy hey so guess what my eye and
foot having coming
uh I can't say well bye no no Holt left
his room he's on his way here oh we
gotta get everyone out of the hallway
all right be quiet everybody
listening to you where's Amy she's great
at shushing all these dum-dums are under
35 yes
attention everyone has to clear the
hallway right now
wow she is great at shushing I know
she's like a librarian you mean like a
sexy librarian no a regular one
hey Captain what's up uh which room is
Sergeant Jeffords oh Terry's in here
with me and Amy we're just having a
low-key night watching House Hunters
International this orthodontist wants to
live in Panama with his no he knows K13
says we are G2G Amy this shush is lifted
oh
[Applause]
[Laughter]
theme song remix
hey Captain are you just waking up it's
11 A.M no no I'm just I worked out so
much this morning you know squat 400 on
the bench push
Terry Terry Terry
Terry
hold is here he wants his presentation
the presentation I didn't do it I just
need that color it'll only take two
minutes okay no problem I've definitely
got two minutes worth of stall material
okay in the meantime why don't you and I
just chat you know for a couple minutes
about prompts prompts
hahaha
where are you on the presentation Jake
all the laptop isn't he here it's gone
uh I'm worried if you're going up
against Jeffrey will color be enough I
was thinking slide transition very well
you may add cross dissolves but so help
me God's efforts if I see even one star
white star wipe Rosa was just headed to
the gym Rosa I need you to work out with
hope for the next half hour cool this is
invigorating isn't it
[Music]
laptop you kind of out of control last
night I was not although pretty sure my
ribs are broken and I think I'm wearing
a pillowcase I cut holes in it oh yeah a
boot print the pool
damn it no sound on the laptop what were
we doing here look there's a shirt it
looks burnt because I was on fire hence
the pillow shirt It's All Coming Back
oh no
no
it was just that one memory this was a
dead end
the state troopers bought fireworks yes
we're unraveling the mystery it's like
we're detectives it's like The Hangover
I am so psyched for your presentation to
the board I'm sure it's gonna be amazing
I'm gonna crush you like a cannibal I
don't doubt it well I'm off to do some
squats Holt dumbass
Kurt browneller how did I catch on fire
oh no I just remember something Terry
feels bad
what the hell was that
oh yeah
yeah what was that loud crash I think
that might have been me see you in hell
partner
oh oh my God it was a her you were
replacing Amy not me what have I done
forward did you guys see that he put the
bag down behind the plant
check the bag not everyone has my
combination of Elegance and charm and
Grace and Poise and then just gift
ability some would say Jiff but then
someone also say syrup wait what
[Laughter]
we could talk to him through an earpiece
and tell him what to say okay
nervous I can feel my legs that never
happens something's wrong skull what are
you wearing you're going home today but
I couldn't let you leave without asking
you out Cindy shot Cindy shots
can I buy you a drink I'm not interested
earpiece fell in what on Earth took you
so long gotta let him be himself in the
end I decided to just go with your
original black and white yeah it's
probably even one color too many anyways
in you go looking good Diaz lightning
okay uh hello I'm captain Raymond Holt
and oh no next slide next next I see
what's happening here uh due to an issue
with the internet Cloud you are seeing a
series of pictures that have nothing to
do with me or the 99th priest oh man you
really be a lot more careful about
leaving laptops lying around for next
year
consequences let's destroy him oh
detective Diaz filling an iron with
tequila so I can make tequila Steam
I even came to Rochester hey it's all
right Scully we'll find a way to make it
up to him no it's not about him Jake I'm
just sad because I'm an unlovable sack
of fungus and I'm gonna be alone forever
oh oh wow now we know scully's not
perfect his hands smell like clams and
yeah over 75 of his body has died Gina
you can stop
when I first met him I was intrigued I'm
not interested in that confident people
are mean and selfish wait you liked
awkward Scully giraffe heart Scully oh
my god he has a giraffe heart oh I bet
it pushes on his organs
yeah you're really into that hey hey
this is your joke oh that's okay I don't
know any jokes either I slept in a body
bag last night
[Music]
do you know what disappoints me most
about this picture that I'm not in it I
can't remember the last time I saw the
nine nine so happy I wish I'd been in
that photo and we are still in Rochester
I think you know what I'm saying what a
thermometer look at the Mercury
[Music]
yes excuse me sir can you take a picture
of us
everybody say Daniel Gabriel Fahrenheit
now do one for Celsius oh God oh God
good stuff good stuff all around yeah
buddy like a good party episode I like a
good party episode I was a big fan of
the movie The Hangover and The Hangover
too is all right hanging with three not
so good The Hangover movies another
fascinating Trilogy of films so yeah I
thought that this was actually a really
fun episode a lot of good lessons to be
learned you want to be part of the group
I remember when uh
this channel hit 30 000 subscribers
through a little party
there's like eight people there
and then uh blacked out
really early on
and they all had fun
they got a half naked took a bunch of
photos some even posing on top of me
while I was blacked out
I woke up the next day feeling very very
left out
hmm
I don't know those parties are for
children
I don't need to have them anymore yeah
they're for people with no direction in
life channels
something to be taken seriously
that's a true story that I just uh
this is true
and um yeah it was an interesting event
but anyway yeah it's a nice wraparound I
don't really
see I don't really I mean I got the
emotional point that Holt was making
I still feel like his character would
have been very upset yes a nice button
for the episode
and a nice good heart to have at the
same time I'm like yeah this guy though
I think he would have been really upset
and and uh Peralta would have had to
really do something make up for it
however the rest of the episode itself
was really fun I like the reveal that it
was his enemy who actually sabotaged the
whole thing I was cleverly done
and uh the party gimmicks and such were
really really funny and uh everything
with the robot and Boyle I thought was
great and hungover hijinks were great
yeah this was a really funny episode
this was this was fun and it's about the
importance of community more than
anything else not being on the board of
directors to make a difference in the
policing Department to make our world
better yeah yeah no no only only selfish
Pursuits and desires it's about beating
your enemies and it's about indulging to
the fullest extent with your trusted
codery of companions yes yeah and a
little bit of being yourself you know be
your weird self and find your weird
match yeah I feel you ever like I feel
like there's an alternate version of
this episode where there's like a halt
storyline where it's just him doing
stuff because yeah like I like the wrap
around at the end but it felt like there
was an act to his story missing to get
us there felt like we went from does
that felt like finding the laptop was
most of that yeah and then everything
else kind of wrapped up right after but
it was very fun very pleasant I would go
to a Brooklyn Nine-Nine party
and uh I feel gonna be a lot of fun to
party with these guys yeah these I mean
this Precinct in particular of course
have you guys ever been so hungover like
like that or do you just forget
everything from the new form that
happened twice it's not fun really it's
not fun yeah it's not fun at all oh damn
but
they make for uh reasonably okay stories
I think sure
it's funny I've never I've never been
there you haven't I've never been that
drunk well I only have an experienced
life apparently not
a real raw experience has come down to
John that's true I know I haven't
experienced [__] in this life
um but yeah damn yeah
this is nice I just want to give
everyone a hug I really like scully's
story though yeah it was nice to get a
spotlight on him in a way that was like
kind of earnest kind of deer like he's
still he's still Scully but uh
especially that thing where they're
talking through his ear I'm like of
course this cannot
I like when the quirky weird people find
love and they'll find the right partner
for that you know even I'm not a big fan
of the movie
I'm actually you know what I say like I
don't like the movie I like the movie uh
the Anchorman sequel whatever that one's
called The Legend of Ron Burgundy uh
I've seen like three or four times and I
still forget the title Anchorman is the
Legend of Ron Burgundy
Anchor Man Too
no yeah let's check no it's got to be
called something what's Anchorman too
check that
the legend continued The Legend
Continues okay yeah because the first
one is the legend of run burgundy
and uh and that guy's name is Andy Daly
there we go that guy I think he I've
seen that guy pop up in a lot of stuff
and I think he's pretty funny and uh I
would like to see more of him in the
future has he popped up on this show as
a doctor I feel like he's popped up in
something like as a doctor no a Silicon
Valley there you go he was on Silicon
Valley as the doctor everybody keeps
seeing
but uh I thought because he was such a
comedic he's such a notable comedic
guest star I was like oh damn you know
we're gonna see him some more but
yeah he was great here oh good
my original Point sure Anchorman too uh
the relationship with Kristen Wiig and
Steve Carell
for some reason I really like that [__]
or even in the office
I really like the weird romances when
you're like don't just there's something
about the message I've always liked
um you know like if you're guessing the
movie Hitch sure I haven't actually but
sure sure
he said I was like has he uh I was more
like sure good example
well it has one of those lessons those
hitch is about
a guy who helps you find love you know
primes yeah you know Playa and wingman
when it comes down to it it's it's it
the message is like oh no you should
just be yourself and find the person who
loves you for being yourself
and I thought that was a nice thing with
Scully yeah because you know in real
life no one ever loved that kind of
fruit of course not what you should just
die right now but in a show medium it's
a nice sweet sentimental message it's a
nice thing to provide false hope to the
viewers yeah yeah like who behave like
Scully good luck good luck to you you're
you're almost as bad as being uh as
Hitchcock is that fungi oh I don't bite
you in the ass overtake your brain
but overall fun episode all around nice
to see everyone let loose they all
deserved it ladies and gentlemen what
did you think give a good hungover story
in the comments
last but not least the sentence with a
patron
Daniel Gallagher you're in Scotland
which means stereotypes dictate that you
could probably tolerate a very mean
hangover and if ever anybody was the
person you know if we had like a big
Patron party right we got everyone
together finally in one room on one
continent it's just go nuts hijinks
you're one of the people who I would
want with us helping us remember the
clues and piece it all together at the
end because I mean both you know I bet
his his CH you need somebody with an
accent and any comedic Ensemble I think
it just fleshes things out a little bit
sure and then uh his knowledge of
various chemistries can make for a lot
of good jokes when it comes to us you
know drinking and stuff in the in the
moment before all the craziness goes
down but then afterwards he can probably
use his knowledge of various uh you know
chemicals and things to help us solve
the mystery and get out of you know
whatever situations we're in because the
cops will probably be on our tail and he
knows a little bit about forensics which
come in handy So Daniel get on out here
and uh and uh we'll get you we'll all
get drinks together and we can black out
and then uh you know go on an adventure
let's do this
St Patrick's Day is next month but this
will get a head start
he's not Irish
yeah but you know I mean that's true you
know that was a really gross uh false
equivalence I just drew there Scottish
people don't celebrate St Patrick's Day
just Americans and Irish people
laughs